[Music]
Selena Gomez might be pumping the brakes
on getting serious with Justin Bieber
again I like to choose to live my life
in a way where I want to be wait freeze
a source tells ET Selena ingesting quote
no a serious relationship right now is
just too much to take on adding that
they remain very friendly and civil in
fact the duo even attended the same
Hillsong Church service in LA Wednesday
night but did not arrive or leave
together
despite Gelinas on-again off-again
status our source adds things aren't
awkward between the two Selena is just
putting herself first quote she's tired
of taking on other people's drama and
just wants to continue focusing on
herself and going to church is a big
part of that I'm constantly somebody
that likes to grow and feel like alright
what could I be better at what could I
do better out apparently the status of
Justin and Selena's relationship is more
uncomfortable for their friends
considering the pair's rocky past there
have been ups and downs in my life
according to the source everyone is
bracing themselves for it to turn south
again but so far it's been fine
[Music]
[Applause]